i'd hoped to make good time today with
some help from the sale provided by my
friends at the schleswig-holstein
inventors club but then the wind died
down after a short stop in the village
store i head out sailless 45 sweaty
kilometers later i desperately need to
change with aching achilles tendons and
rubbery legs i've set a new personal
record 63 clicks go vigga go
the first exhausting days of my
challenge are behind me but what did i
get myself into here the lowest point of
germany is supposed to be nearby however
so it should be possible
to roll down there without much effort
the lowest point in germany lies exactly
three point five three nine meters below
sea level in the town of noyendorf's
aximbanda i've come 337 kilometers on
the scooter since i started in zult
compared to germany's highest mountain
the tsuxbitsa the lowest point seems
terribly understated
but then it's also a little more shall
we say anticlimactic
there it is a huge three and a half
meters below sea level and i'm standing
right in front of it
yeah it's a great feeling
but where are all the visitors
i decide to ask the only other tourist
here
why aren't there as many people here as
there are for example at germany's
highest point that suits pizza
well when you're driving along here you
don't really notice you're germany's
lowest point
we don't see anything you don't notice
anything it's just flat there's no water
you think it would be underwater
so unspectacular
but the general population's ignorance
of this geographical gem doesn't keep
people from fighting about it around 200
kilometers west of here the town of
flaipzum claims to have an even lower
point don't believe them though this
one's at least a meter deeper
of course the lowest point of germany is
a tourist attraction as well therefore
the citizens of neundorf have put up a
large poll and a parking place and some
benches and tables to mark the claim to
the title of the lowest point of germany
but let's get a little perspective here
the lowest point on land on the planet
lies on the shore of the dead sea 420
meters below sea level and then there's
the deepest point on earth the bottom of
the marianas trench is a staggering 11
kilometers beneath the surface of the
pacific
okay so it's not all that impressive
still surely it deserves more than this
shouldn't germany's lowest point get a
little more fanfare maybe like a 50
meter high memorial
no we have the building the parking lot
and the plaque that says germany's
lowest point
we think that's enough
because the lowest point speaks for
itself okay
too bad it just feels like something's
missing
not everyone is aware that this place is
unique in germany three and a half
meters don't seem to be that impressive
to some so i have decided to change this
i'm collecting signatures to have the
highest point in germany be replaced in
all the school books with the lowest
point in germany out with the tsukesh
pizza in with here are you with me
i'm collecting a thousand euros from
every town resident to make germany's
lowest point more famous all over the
world
why not
it's clear the people of noyendorf's
oxenbanda cherish their landmark
everyone here signed my petition and i
even collected two euros fifty
like a migrating bird it's time once
again for me to head south left leg
right leg left leg right
after germany's lowest point i'm looking
forward to some highlights ahead